So what do you want
to do tonight?
Like, I was thinking
maybe we could meet up
with Amy and Brad,
and, like, before that,
we could go to Angela's,
and before that,
we could, like, just go--
Meegan.
I have something
to say.
[exhales sharply]
I had to say it
in person
because it's--
it's, like, super important.
Okay.
Um...
I know this is sudden,
but, like,
I've been thinking
about this for a while.
And I know this is something
that needs to happen.
I'm breaking up
with you.
Cool.
Love it.
Totally fine
with that.
- R-Really?
- Yeah.
'Cause I thought--
I was really worried
that you were
gonna be, like, mad.
Mad?
Oh, my God.
Are you kidding me?
No, of course
I'm not mad.
People grow apart.
It happens.
It's, like,
part of life.
No, I'm totally fine.
Like, love it,
love it, love it.
Um...
[clears throat]
So...
Uh, um...
we had a good run.
Yeah.
And, uh, don't be
a stranger.
Can I just--
Can I ask why?
- Why?
- Yeah, like, whatevs.
Like, I'm doing some work
on myself
and, like, trying to grow
as a person,
so I'd really, like,
appreciate to know why.
Yeah, um...
Okay, yeah,
that's, like--
You know, I think
that you're kind of, like,
a controlling
person who--
Thank you.
Thank you for that.
That's nice.
Cool.
No problem.
So you know what
your problem is, Andre?
What?
You keep tabs
on people.
Every little thing
somebody does,
you have to keep
a tab of it.
Wait. I-I can't tell
if you're angry or not.
I'm not.
Mm, totally not angry.
No, I'm excited.
It's good.
It's just, like,
you said your piece,
and I just think
that I deserve the human decency
to say my piece.
Right, right.
Is that--
is that not okay?
No, no, no.
It's--
Of course, of course.
You're a controlling,
manipulative person.
Everyone says that.
I-I don't think
that I am.
Yes, you are, Andre.
Yes, you mother[bleep] are.
Okay, now--now,
you sound pretty angry.
I'm not angry!
I'm not angry.
I'm fine.
I love it!
I love that you came
to my house,
and you broke up with me
in my space.
And I'm gonna think about that
every time I'm here.
That's great.
That is so perfect for me.
[crying]
It's the best thing
that's ever happened to me.
Where else was
I supposed to do it?
'Cause you won't come
to my house.
Oh, here he is.
The puppet master is back.
But I'm not--
No, I'm not the puppet master.
Why are you
doing this to me?
It's true.
You won't come to my house.
You said my apartment
looks like two rats
just [bleep] in it
every [bleep] day.
Oh, right,
like, thank you for that.
I'm a bitch.
Thank you.
I didn't call--
no, I didn't say "bitch."
- I didn't--
- Which is it?
Am I evil,
or am I a bitch?
No, no, you're
not evil, Meegan.
Well, then why
are you punishing me?
I'm not punishing you.
I'm not--
You broke up with me,
and I'm not supposed
to feel punished.
- Who thinks like that?
- [shouting]
I don't know!
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry,
okay, Meegan?
I guess I didn't think
it through.
Well, it's, like,
too late now.
- I mean, we're done.
- No, it's not too late.
Meegan, Meegan,
seriously, I just--
I-I-I had a feeling
that I thought was true,
and clearly--
clearly it wasn't true.
Like, I'm so confused.
Like, are you
breaking up with me,
or are you not
breaking up with me?
Meegan, I'm not
breaking up with you!
Okay, cool. So what do you want
to do tonight?
Like, I want to hang out
with Amy and Brad,
but maybe before that,
we can go to Angela's.
[dark music]
♪ ♪
What just happened?